là ce qui était très intéressant dans ce
mouvement d gilet jaune ce qu'on avait
une recomposition des gens qui sont
venus d'ailleurs sur les ronds points
sans aucun appel politique syndical ou
autre donc il ya bien la force une
puissance j'allais dire intrinsèque du
dossier de ces gens ordinaires et ce qui
était phrase fascinant c'est la lecture
que les médias mais aussi on va dire les
experts ont eu ce mouvement tout d'abord
il ya eu l'état de sidération
que se passe-t-il qui sont ils
avec des entrepôts log modernes qui sont
allés même visiter les appartements
gharb et comment mangent-ils ont-ils un
écran 16 9ème dans leur appartement
tiens c'est étrange il manifeste mais
ils ont des iphone sous entendu ils ne
sont pas légitimes
et ça c'est d'ailleurs très nouveau
c'est la première fois d'ailleurs donc
dans un mouvement social
je vois des journalistes d'enquêté
savoir si telle gilet jaune part en
vacances aux sables d'olonne où un
possèdent ou non un écran 16 9ème
on n'a jamais vu ça dans aucun mouvement
social de jeu pas de cheminots ou autre
on sait qu'on se pose pas la question de
comment vivent les gens et là on a eu
finalement ces enquêtes avec cette idée
qui était très très très clair
finalement ils ne sont pas vraiment
légitime
et puis on a eu un générique qui s'est
mis en place
ce grand débat était assez assez
intéressant d'ailleurs le grand débat
initié par emmanuel macron comme vous
les avez pu le voir le grand débat est
organisé par segmentation un parent par
donc on avait un débat avec les maires
ruraux
nous avons eu un débat avec les femmes
ou les femmes célibataires les jeunes
bref il s'agissait pour nos politiques
publicitaires ou panélistes de politique
de réglementer ce qui venait de se
recomposer
[Musique]